our next guest guest excuse me is on a
mission
to make the young men and women of today
have endless
opportunities tomorrow by providing
professional coaching and internships
for students of color and that's why she
is today's drew gooder
yes but most importantly she is the
definition of intrepid please welcome
halima nash
hello halima hello drew
so happy to be here by the way you're
stunning
i have been doing all of my research on
you but
meow you're gorgeous i can't help it i'm
one of those women like i'd have no
filter and
i act as if it can all go away tomorrow
so i might as well tell everyone i love
them today
um and i do i really have the deepest
respect for you
where did your passion for mentoring
students come from
well you know i understood the power of
mentoring at a very early age drew
you know i am the first in family to go
to college
attended howard university and i really
needed
those voices and mirrors to really see
what i could be
and what i could accomplish and the
whole reason why i started this company
rosecransventures
was this desire to use social
entrepreneurship to be in service
to the younger me and to be the person
that my younger self needed
and i have to say that you've been doing
this in person but when the pandemic hit
your prowess of problem solving
was just incredible i mean it was so
effective
i you know i have to tell you you know
there's there are ways that we all have
figured out how to pivot
in this pandemic but for me i've been
doing numbers for rose crane's ventures
doing virtual coaching
but it was really trying to figure out
how to keep students motivated and keep
their morale up during the pandemic that
was really the toughest thing
students being displaced from their
campuses students really trying to wrap
their mind around like okay i'm a
freshman now i gotta move back home
and try to figure this out reminding
them you're still brilliant you're still
amazing
you know i had a student that was on the
verge of interning at nasa
and once the internship got cancelled
you know how do i make sure that the
students knows that
you know even though that was a small
blip even though that might not be an
opportunity you can have this summer
we're still going to find something for
you and i was able to replace
100 of the cancelled internships and
turn them into virtual internships
and i happen to know um how grateful
everyone is actually have something to
show you
miss nash because of you and all the
things you've done
creating opportunities for us i have
been able to
successfully complete three internships
a lot of mentors like to talk but you
like to listen
and that's what i think makes you just a
great friend above
anything and everything else i want to
thank miss nash for everything she's
done for me
honestly without her i don't feel like i
would have reached my full potential
your ability to just pair people with
different opportunities is phenomenal
and it's something
that is a lifelong gift that i am
planning to take with me
throughout this whole journey and i
really want to thank you for that
well miss nash i have to say i
know i would not be sitting here and i
would not be anywhere if people hadn't
believed in me
and took me on and given me tough love
and guided me
and helped me and shaped my
opportunities and we want to help you
continue
to shape our future leaders so our
friends at
h m are going to provide you with ten
thousand dollars worth of gift cards
to help you professionally outfit your
students for their internship
thank you halima for everything that you
do she'll be on our website at the
drewbravemore show.com
you are amazing thank you for being on
this show we'll be right back
thank you
you